you all right son
we need to know what he knows he doesn't
even know what he knows
[Music]
it's a ship we've come to the right
place Superman
he claims he's from the 31st century I'm
Jessica
everyone knows limelight the fatal fiber
coming well we'll do Justice League
[Music]
I didn't know you had powers Thomas what
problems would be by the first of your
cities to be flattered
hand over the Lancer we don't negotiate
with terrorists even the 31st century
kind we stop our enemies before they
even start
no one's responding to our car
[Music]
I heard you were grabby just got a
message from the fatal five Bruce was
saying that he didn't want to do a movie
where the Justice League sort of cloud
through faceless parademons that he
wanted very specific unique opponents
for them to face and the fatal 550 bill
a lot of DC fans myself included love
the Legion of super-heroes and when the
fatal five came up we said well this is
a great way for us to do a Justice
League story but bring in some great
cameos from the the Legionnaires and we
love so much the story of specifically I
think it's the characters that really
drew me into it it's exciting to see
these young teenagers and their setting
and in their world kind of battling an
enemy that they have been battling for
four years and we just kind of jump
right to that
[Music]
hey everybody its Charlie I got a lot of
requests to make a video for the Justice
League vs the fatal five animated DC
movie that's coming up they're gonna
release it on the DC streaming service
just like they did for reign of the
Superman so I'll explain what's going on
but as you probably recognized a lot of
the voices this is Bruce Timm and his
old crew from Batman the Animated Series
coming back to do a lot of voices so
like we have Kevin Conroy is Batman the
animation style is also in keeping with
the style from Batman the Animated
Series so if you're not a big animation
geek Bruce Timm is sort of like a Kevin
Feige esque figure inside Warner
Brothers animation for all the DC movies
and for the most part all the stuff that
he's done Batman the animated series
Batman Beyond all the animated movies
like mask of the phantasm all of that
stuff is on the DC streaming service
right now we are doing a new round of
they gave away for the DC Universe
service all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your favorite
animated DC movie on the video as you
could probably tell from the trailer the
main characters of this movie are
Jessica Cruz Green Lantern from the new
52 in star boy of the Legion of the
superheroes it's the fatal five coming
back in time from the 31st century to
try and use Jessica Cruz Green Lantern
to change history so that the Green
Lantern Corps aren't a threat to them in
the future
they released this really long special
episode about the movie itself talking
about all the characters and everything
it's a 10 minutes long I can't post the
entire thing here but here's a couple of
clips from that of them talking about
the characters and what's going on
Jessica's a story in particular I find
really fascinating it's always
interesting to me to see a character who
is not necessarily a reluctant superhero
but somebody who doesn't just like you
know have the the superhero thing thrust
upon them they're just like okay yeah
let's go let's go fight crime you know I
mean she's really ambivalent about it
because she's got like almost crippling
anxiety she could barely leave the house
and it's like wow that's that's that's
something you don't really see in a
superhero I remember being thrilled when
we had Diane Guerrero come in to record
for her first session and and she just
kind of gave me this wide-eyed look of
this girl in a sense to where I think
she could really relate to some of the
struggles and some of the inner demons
that Jessica had there was something
about Jessica that felt very personal
and very intimate and very vulnerable
and and still powerful and still
managing that that she is working act
something that we thought was really
relatable one of the early things that
Jim Craig and I bonded over was was we
both were just obsessed with and loved
the Legion of super-heroes and starboy
was a mutual favorite Eric absolutely
said oh we need to use Star bullying and
I think that he has a great emotional
arc and it should be really satisfying
this character is struggling with
keeping his grip on reality due to not
having a prescription or medicine that
he would have in his own time that's not
great as he comes back to our time you
see someone who's so capable start to
lose his faculties it's really quite
tragic
he definitely has troubles I mean he has
manic modes and memory problems and
severe trouble with staying focused on
things in the present elias Cobell
brought so much of the humor and I think
likable side to Thomas Keller and star
boy
mind if I join you it's star boy right
star boy is this nurturing element of
Jessica and she's a calming force for
him as well God so hard I can't think I
can't remember they're kind of like
dealing with their own thing and they
and you know they don't feel like
anybody understands them
but somehow when they're together they
sort of comfort and support each other a
lot of times in superhero stories mental
illness can get ascribed to villains
like Batman's rogues gallery is kind of
the big example of this but here we had
a chance to take to neuro atypical
people and you stigmatize it and have
them find each other and help each other
and you know kind of get out of their
way and not act as if they're damaged in
some way and just let them be heroes and
I think that was really fun for all of
us to do and tackle they both need each
other to overcome their problems and
kind of rise above their own personal
challenges in order to face the ultimate
evil if you guys didn't recognize her
the actors that's playing Jessica Cruz
Green Lantern is the same actress that's
playing crazy Jane in real life on the
Doom Patrol TV show which is premiering
at the end of this week as I'm posting
the video so this Justice League versus
the fatal five is sort of a standalone
movie it doesn't have anything to do
with the continuity of what's going on
during reign of the supermen but if
you're not a big comic book reader the
story that they're doing for the Jessica
Cruz Green Lantern is very similar to
her comic book origin during the new 52
it's all about overcoming trauma and
learning to control her willpower so she
in starboy have sort of parallel arcs
because he's very literally losing his
mind because he doesn't have the
medication that he needs from the 31st
century if you're not familiar with the
fatal five like they say during this
they're just classic Legion of
super-heroes villains that shown up in
the comics a couple times Legion of
super-heroes is a comic book that gets
cancelled all the time they keep trying
to bring it back and it always gets
canceled pretty quickly so if you've
been looking for more Legion of
super-heroes there'll be a nice change
of pace from the other characters that
have been popping up in the other DC
animated movies right now but right now
they're saying the digital
release date is March 30th and the
blu-ray release is April 15th based on
the way that they released reign of the
Superman if you have the DC streaming
service right now you will be able to
get the movie for free but I don't think
that they're gonna post it on the
streaming service for you to watch until
the DVD is released April 15th so if you
want to watch it earlier than that you
do have to pay extra but if you're
already paying the seven or eight
dollars a month for the DC streaming
service then you don't have to pay extra
money if you just wait a couple extra
weeks you'll be able to get this Justice
League vs the fatal five movie for free
in all future DC animated movies it's
the same thing but like I said they're
probably not making it available on the
service till the blu-ray is our beliefs
so it'll be the same thing for future
animated movies but that is good news
that you can get the movie for free if
you just wait a couple extra weeks there
is supposed to be a new Shazam trailer
in the next week or two so I'll do a
video for that when it drops but leave
all your DC video requests in the
comments below click here for the reign
of the Superman post credits scene and
click here for all my Young Justice
season 3 videos thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]